[Musik]
Ich habe keine Angst davor, ja, weil ich weiß,
was das ist,
es wird vielleicht ein bisschen arrogant klingen,
aber auch bitter
, so
versuchen meine Gegner, mich zu disqualifizieren, sie sagen:
Ja, geh und hör ihm zu, das ist es  etwas neues
, aber nimm es nicht zu ernst
gut
ich denke immer noch, dass du beides
tun kannst, was du amüsant und
gleichzeitig sehr ernst und sehr
kurz sein
kannst, damit ich mich nicht verliere, werde ich dir sagen,
warum ich  Ich habe hier eine Theorie, die sehr tragisch ist.
Haben Sie
bemerkt,
dass die besten Filme über den
Holocaust Komödien sind,
la vita bella und andere, denn wenn der
Terror ein gewisses Maß erreicht
, kann man es nicht
als Tragödie tun. Eine Tragödie bedeutet, dass es
mir leid tut  das beispiel des schlechten geschmacks
wenn ich dich quäle benimmst du
dich immer noch wie ein held du sagst nein du
öffnest deinen atem mach was du willst ich
werde es nicht tun aber sorry wenn du wirklich
an einem ort wie
auschwitz oder gulag bist verlierst du diese würde
und das einzige  Der Weg, es zu überleben, ist
durch dummen Humor und i  Ich kann bestätigen,
dass
Witze zu geschmacklos sind. Ich werde es nicht geben,
aber Sie wissen, dass es eine ganze
Unterart von Auschwitz-Humor im Bosnischen der
zerebralen Nischen gab,
nicht weil ich nicht wirklich tiefsinnig bin,
hoffe ich, dass ich es in gewissem Sinne
bin, sondern weil Sie wissen, dass ich es bin  nicht der übliche marxist meine
botschaft ist sehr
pessimistisch okay
ich werde langsam müde von dieser rhetorikfigur
von mir das dingus in abbar
unter umgekehrt ist es nicht so, dass
wir heute ziemlich oft eine art doppeltrick finden wie in der ukraine
Diejenigen, die in gewisser Weise gegen die
russische Aggression hätten sein sollen
, geben zu, leugnen jedoch die offensichtliche Tatsache, dass
Russland ein kleineres Land angegriffen hat, und
Sie wissen, was der übliche Ausdruck ist, nein, nein,
es ist nicht so einfach, die Dinge sind
komplexer, sodass manchmal der Hinweis
auf Tiefe und Komplexität erfolgen kann  wir
vergessen die offensichtliche tatsache
sorry aber um einen philosophischen scherz zu machen
vergesse ich manchmal das ich kein
deutsch spreche weißt du
ich tue es einfach nein aber ganz im ernst
jetzt sage ich nochmal was um die leute zu schockieren
aber ich meine  Es ist so ernst,
meine Lösung ist, dass ich mich entschuldige, und ich meine es
sehr ernst,
meine Lösung, um all diese Probleme zu überleben,
und langsam Leugnung zu bekommen, ist
willkürlich.
Ich denke, dass die Nazis
diese Idee
nur brutal missbraucht haben  Witz natürlich,
dass die Schweiz nicht
funktioniert, macht dich nicht frei, aber ich denke,
was es dir ermöglicht, in diesen verrückten Zeiten zu überleben.
Ich habe Probleme mit meiner
Krankheit. Ich mache mir Sorgen um die Situation bei der
Arbeit  gepflegtes
ritual
ein arbeitsplatz ein neues stickchen zum essen um
jeden preis als ich neulich kaffee getrunken habe und
es war kein ernster aber ich war sehr
fertig die arbeit ging weiter
es muss sein
ich würde mich nicht als kreativ bezeichnen es ist zu
arrogant aber  Arbeit, die
dir etwas bedeutet, das zutiefst befriedigend ist, ich
kann nicht überleben
, verschenken,
ich nenne das ironisch ökologisches
Schreiben, du weißt, ich recycele,
okay,
was ich ernsthaft sagen möchte,
ist, dass ich diese Pfadfindermentalität habe,
wenn
ich nicht wenigstens etwas mache  ein ... Lesen  Und
ich schreibe jeden Tag, ich fühle mich schuldig, habe ich es
verdient, nein und so weiter,
aber es gibt nichts, was mich glücklicher macht,
als
das richtige Wort zu erfinden. Sie als
Philosoph müssen auch wissen, dass
Sie oft die richtige Idee haben, aber sie
in der Luft schwebt  du vermisst das richtige
wort und dann plötzlich, wenn diese
welt kommt
, die so nah ist, wie ich es nenne, nennen wir
es leicht obszön mentaler orgasmus
ähm
[musik]
ich denke nicht auf
mystische oder
orientalische weise,
aber ich denke nicht an tot
Tod,
meine äh
Lösung hier ist
äh
, wissen Sie, in Frankreich gibt es Witze über die
Machiala-Polizei, die
Tautologien Dummheiten erzählt, aber mit einer
gewissen Weisheit, und
in den Witzen, als dieser Monsieur, die Polizei, starb,
war
ein Satz eine halbe Minute, bevor
er tot war, Raketenpolizei  immer noch
am leben
das ist meine einstellung ich glaube nicht
dass man das
domestizieren kann
aber ich glaube
zutiefst dass das für mich keine metapher ist
in deinem leben zu leben
als ein
lebender tod
leben das in dem sinne für mich das schreiben
ist alr  bereitwillig zu akzeptieren, dass du tot bist, sagte
der eine philosoph, zu dem ich sonst
nicht die beste beziehung hatte
, sehr schön, dass es etwas
testamentarisches gibt, als ob du bereits
tot in jeder
schrift bist, es geht darum, nicht vom tod besessen zu
sein, es geht darum, einfach  akzeptiere es
als ein dummes kontingentes Detail, denke nicht
darüber nach, sondern akzeptiere es und arbeite dann weiter
, bis du
innerlich zusammenbrichst
der geist
scheinknochen wo man sich widersetzt oder
die gegensätze identifiziert
wenn man sich darin
zufrieden gibt
und meine idee war diese dann ist mir aufgefallen
das viele der heutigen philosophen nicht als
philosophen nicht nur heute wie
sie wissen in den kognitionswissenschaften daniel
danette
richard dawkins und so weiter i don
Sie ist eine dieser Kognitionswissenschaftler,
die ich sehr schätze, und er hat
auch diese Idee entwickelt, dass Sie nicht immer eine
Aktion haben  r gehirn
funktioniert
wie
wie wie von viren besetzt das
gedanken sind viren die
uns im grunde kontrollieren und der große schock ich mag
diese unerwarteten verbindungen du weißt
wer die erste war die diese idee entwickelt hat
sie wird meist als
konservativ langweilig abgetan ich schätze dich
viel mehr als  dostoevsky leo tolstoy
sie sagte die ganze theorie, dass unser
geist kontrolliert wird sie nennt sie nicht
viren sondern basilikum
die sich selbst reproduzieren
und
so
meine idee ist dass
unser geist jetzt schon
in gewissem sinne
von viren besetzt ist unsere gedanken das
entfremdete symbolsystem  die
sich durch uns reproduziert,
äh,
aber nein, du findest sogar das süß, ich
stimme seiner Formulierung nicht zu, du erinnerst dich an
den anderen Richard Dawkins, ich glaube, er
hat diese Idee von Memen entwickelt.
Ja, Memes sind Viren des Geistes, die sie
benutzt,
und wir sind gerecht  ein Medium für die Mems
, um sich selbst zu reproduzieren, dann
können wir auf der höheren Ebene der Spekulation sogar
sagen, dass mein Gott der
Kapitalismus selbst ein Virus ist
Ja, es ist ein virtuelles anonymes System,
das dennoch reguliert, und daher wäre
meine hegelsche
Formel Nick der Geist ist und
Kenohan, aber ihr Geist ist in
und so
konfrontierte uns dieser Pandemievirus mit der
Tatsache, dass wir nicht ausnahmsweise
in einem Universum leben  von
Viren
[Musik]
Ich möchte etwas Ernstes sagen, da
Sie sehr gut angefangen haben, es ist nicht
nur die Pandemie oder jetzt der Krieg, wir befinden uns
wirklich in einer Zeit von
vier Reitern der Apokalypse,
heute hat es begonnen, der erste Reiter ist die
Pest, die Pestviren und so weiter  dann ist der zweite
reiter krieg
wir sind jetzt
in einem krieg möglicherweise ist es vielleicht ein
neuer weltkrieg dann ist es der hunger jeder
weiß jetzt wegen der rolle der ukraine
und der
ukraine und russlands bei der versorgung
der welt mit weizen besteht eine ernsthafte
möglichkeit des hungers
auch die globale Erwärmung und so weiter und dann,
was der vierte Reiter Tod wäre, den
ich hören würde, machte
eine zeitgemäßere Wendung, nicht so sehr
der übliche Tod, der
Tod ist Teil des Lebens, wenn mich Leute
nach dem Tod fragen  Das, was ich vergessen habe, ist, dass ich
mein beliebtestes Graffiti zitiere,
das zu Zeiten von Solidarnosk in Polen beliebt war.
Es ist die beste
Definition des Lebens, die man sich vorstellen kann. Das
Leben ist eine Krankheit, die
durch Sex übertragen wird und immer mit dem Tod endet  Das ist nicht
ganz richtig,
aber was ich sagen will, ist das und ich
habe ein Buch darüber geschrieben,
dass
viel wichtiger als das
physische biologische Leben das Überleben der
Folgen von
Ich weiß nicht, was das deutsche Wort
ist  fernet
netzwerk unseres gehirns ich spreche nicht nur von
dieser kapitalistischen digitalen kontrolle alle unsere
bewegungen werden registriert wir nähern uns jetzt
etwas
und wir wissen nicht was wir wirklich meinen auf
einer sehr primitiven ebene ist es schon möglich
das dein gehirn
ist  direkt mit dem computer verbunden
so ein computer kann es ist noch sehr
primitiv aber
registriert direkt deine gedanken jetzt
natürlich stellen uns die medien das als gute
nachricht vor oder du bist total verkrüppelt aber du
denkst nur ab  etwas aus und dann
bewegt sich das ding ja aber es geht auch
andersherum wenn deine gedanken
die dinge direkt in bewegung bringen können dann kann das
digitale universum direkt
eingreifen sprich jeder dadurch
nicht das gefährden was wir spontan
als unsere
innerste freiheit
empfinden können  versklavt im Wandel aber was
in meinem Kopf ist sagen wir mal du bist der schlechte
schwankende Doktor du kannst nicht kontrollieren das es
nicht mehr
sein kann
die Perspektive ist das es gemacht wird
und da diese Distanz zwischen innen
und außen die Basis
unseres Freiheitsgefühls ist  Ich kann zumindest denken, was ich
will, große Vorteile,
nicht in gewissem Sinne der Tod dessen, was wir
zumindest bisher
als Mensch verstehen oder verstanden
haben. Im Folgenden hätte ich es als
zweiten Tod bezeichnet, nicht als physischen
Tod,
sondern selbst wenn wir am Leben sind  Tod dessen,
was wir bisher als
Mensch verstanden haben, deshalb ist es wichtig, dass wir
berücksichtigen, dass wir uns in dieser
schwierigen Situation eines perfekten Sturms befinden,
in dem drei sind  vier krisen bedrohen
uns gleichzeitig ich bin nicht
unbedingt pessimist aber ich denke ich hoffe als
philosoph werden wir dem zustimmen
wir müssen hier mehr denn je denken
als linke drehe ich gerne
marks these 11 immer wieder um.  Philosophen können
die Welt nur interpretiert haben, es ist an der Zeit, sie
auch zu verändern, was wäre, wenn
wir heute eher sagen sollten, dass wir im 20. Jahrhundert
die Welt vielleicht zu
radikal zu schnell verändern wollten und jetzt müssen wir
auf eine tiefere Weise zurückkehren, um die
Philosophie
heute
klar zu interpretieren  Die Grenze Ich werde sehr kurz sein, indem ich
die Beschränkungen von Marx unterbreche.
Zuerst seine Vorstellung von
proletarischer
Identität.
Er hat eine gewisse teleologische
Orientierung auf ein Endziel,
das ich glaube, in sein Denken einzuschreiben,
nämlich dass wir mit der Revolution der
Arbeiterklasse ein proletarisches Selbstbewusstsein sind  in
einer einzigartigen position treten wir aus der
ideologie aus
wir haben einen agenten der weiß was er
tut geschichte wird transparent
ich denke wir sollten hier segal von marx zu
hegel
zurückkehren  für mich mag es verrückt klingen der
philosoph von der öffnung der geschichte
in die zukunft denn ihr wisst was
hegel sagt und ich stimme ihm zutiefst zu
das ist die lektion des 20. jahrhunderts in seiner
äh
fremden philosophie hegel sagt dass die
philosophie nichts
über die bleiben kann  zukunft kann man eine
lebensfigur erst in ihrer
gedanklichen struktur erfassen, wenn diese
lebensfigur schon
verfault ist
also würde sich hegel glaube ich wie ein fünfter
im wasser fühlen im 20. jahrhundert haben wir zuerst
den ausbruch des ersten weltkrieges
alle waren zumindest in europa
optimistisch stetiger fortschritt zweite hälfte
des 19. jahrhunderts dann eine mega katastrophe
dann haben wir stalinismus es fing an wie
eine art
zumindest befreiungsversprechen wir wissen
wo wir sind dann haben wir den fukuyama
moment wir dachten am ende
ist immer sehr aufmerksam  dieser hegel
ist kein billiger optimist wenn man
auch nur den besten plan hat
das ist
wirklich
lister vernon die schlauheit der vernunft sich
sicher zu sein das die dinge irgendwie schief gehen
und was hegel zur
versöhnung aufruft, ist genau die
versöhnung mit diesem notwendigerweise
tragischen ausgang wie trifft dieses video
auf philanthropie
sie wissen was das problem mit den
hegelianern von heute ist ich schätze es ich nenne sie
liberal
hegelianer liberal in dem sinne dass
ihr höchster wert darin besteht
gegenseitige anerkennung zu unterhalten und dann
Sie projizieren einen bestimmten
Zeitplan für die Zukunftsorientierung. Die Idee ist,
dass Segel
eine bestimmte Zukunftsvision
voller Freiheit und gegenseitiger Anerkennung skizziert, aber
er kam zu früh, und dann suchen sie
nach einem echten Hegelianer, um einen
jungen Blick auf seine Spuren zu werfen, nur mit
proletarischer Revolution werden wir  Sei da,
dann haben wir Fukuyama, der dachte, der
hegelsche Moment sei nur die heutige liberale
Demokratie. Wir haben sogar dumme New Ager
, die mit sogenannter Singularität denken,
wann unser Gehirn zu einem
wird, das Hegels absoluter Orgasmus sein wird. Kein Hegel
ist ein viel pessimistischerer Hegel denkt
Zukunft  ist unter
ja und mein problem mit marx ist, dass
er sich capita vorstellt  lism sorry
kommunismus
freudianischer fehler der
kommunismus ist eine zeit dieses ähm
transparenten
drachens, in der die geschichte nicht mehr länger sein wird oder das
system, in dem wir uns befinden, nicht mehr
entfremdet sein wird. wir unser kollektiver verstand wird
in der lage sein,
die situation zu kontrollieren
dass nein, wir werden
nie dahin kommen, dass
unser größter Wunsch nicht die
Selbsttransparenz des sozialen Lebens sein sollte, aber ich
weiß, ich bin hier ironisch, aber ich mag es
und habe
eine gute Entfremdung gut formuliert,
das heißt, wir müssen unsere
menschliche
Entfremdung akzeptieren  In dem Sinne, dass wir nicht
nur Individuen sind, die bei jeder Kommunikation miteinander
kommunizieren, gibt es eine
nur virtuelle Präsenz dessen, was Jacques
Lacon
den Gronk-Otter grob nannte, unter dem großen
anderen, dem anonymen
System, das all diese enorme Unterwasserwelt reguliert.
Ja,
besonders wichtig, kann ich nicht betonen
genug, weil ich denke, dass dies
heute bedroht ist.
Wir sollten nicht unterschätzen, dass
die Rolle ungeschriebener Regeln, die Sie kennen,
Regeln sind, die reg  Wie wichtig unsere Kommunikation ist,
sind nicht nur die expliziten Regeln. Jedes
System
impliziert einen anderen Bereich, der uns sagt,
wie ernst wir die expliziten Regeln nehmen sollten.
Haben Sie zum Beispiel
das gleiche
alltägliche Ritual im täglichen Leben, sagen wir,
Kaffee, Kaffee, nein, nein,
ja, aber sagen wir, ich.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass ich es nicht bin, aber sagen wir, ich bin
reicher als du. Ich lade dich zum Abendessen ein,
also hast du auch dieses äh-
Ritual, dass du, wenn die Rechnung kommt
, ein bisschen rhetorisch darauf bestehen musst,
nein, nein, sagen wir, wir beide wissen es
Sie werden es am Ende akzeptieren, aber wir
müssen dieses Ritual durchlaufen,
und ich denke, würden Sie zustimmen, dass sie mit dem
heutigen
Vulgärpopulismus Trumpismus, aber auch die Linke mit
politischer Korrektheit
diese ungeschriebenen Regeln verletzen oder leugnen
, wie das Problem mit politischer
Korrektheit für mich  ist das
alles, zum beispiel in der sexualität,
das
war explizit
zum beispiel in einer amerikanischen
universität, die ich besucht habe,
sie haben mir gezeigt, dass sie ein buch haben, wenn sie sagen, du
kannst,
wenn du sedu bist  einer dame kannst du
ihr hemd greifen aber nicht
aber nicht oberflächlich aber keinen
knopf öffnen du solltest immer fragen kann ich jetzt
den knopf öffnen und so weiter und so weiter es ist
total total total normal
und ich finde das
sehr gefährlich weil es so nicht geht
unser verstand
arbeitet all unsere nicht nur sexualität, sondern
alltägliche höflichkeit
impliziert etwas trauriges etwas nein gesagtes
etwas gesagtes aber nicht ernst gemeintes
und so weiter das sind
diese drei dummen und hilflosen dinge
das ist
meiner meinung nach heute bedroht es ist etwas genau von jacques
[musik]
[musik  ]
sehr starker einfluss auf mich aber
rhetorisch auf der ebene des verhaltens
ist mir nichts fremder als das was
du gerade beendet hast weißt du es ist
für mich ein gewisser
fake das ist
aber
es ist sehr wichtig hier kommt mein
hegelianismus um zu verstehen was lacon
sagt  Hier richtig sagt er nicht, dass es da
draußen eine Wahrheit gibt,
aber wir können sie nicht vollständig begreifen. Etwas
weicht uns immer aus. Ich denke, dass sein Punkt
viel hegelianischer ist, ja, wir können es nicht sagen  In
Wahrheit ist es immer ein Antagonist,
inkonsistent,
aber dieser Antagonismus und diese Inkonsistenz
sind das Wirkliche selbst,
also ist es nicht so, dass es da draußen ein tieferes, wirkliches,
spärliches Gedankenwesen gibt,
und das ist, glaube ich, ich nehme
hier normalerweise ein sehr einfaches Beispiel
adorno in a very
in an
Der frühe, aber gute Text
über den Gesellschaftsbegriff
vertritt den gleichen Punkt wie Lacon ich behaupte,
wo er sagt, dass wir heute zwei
vorherrschende Gesellschaftsvorstellungen haben, das
Individuum ist liberal, die letztendliche Tatsache
sind Individuen, und so entstehen soziale
Netzwerke aus unserer Interaktion und auf der
andererseits der emil durkheim der kemsche
organismus
gesellschaft ist zuerst als eine totalität die
individuen wachsen daraus dann hat adorno
eine wunderbare
formel gegeben wunderbare antinomie er sagt wir
können diesen antagonismus nicht auflösen
es ist das eine oder andere es gibt keine
synthese aber dann fügt er etwas hinzu
das es ist  gerade dieser antagonismus
zwischen individualität und anonymem
system,
der unsere gesellschaft prägt, ist
das grundstück h  egelscher trick was du für
ein hindernis hältst
ist seine eigene lösung wenn du und das bedeutet
lacong, dass wir durch diesen nicht-alles-antagonismus
inkonsistenz
das reale berühren
das ist realität
es ist rein virtuell es ist keine
substantielle realität hinter uns
eine völlig
formale
Vorstellung, es ist nur ein
abwesender virtueller
Bezugspunkt dessen,
was tatsächlich
existiert, es hat, es hat,
es ist keine positive Entität hinter
verschiedenen Dingen, die passieren,
wenn Sie diese Dinge verstehen wollen,
müssen Sie sich auf eine abwesende virtuelle Entität beziehen, die
nicht göttlich ist, aber sagen wir mal  Ein
Antagonismus,
zu dem all das, was empirisch
existiert,
nicht außerhalb unserer vielfältigen
Versuche existiert, es ist nur ihre Wirkung, die ein
sehr larkanischer Gedanke ist, dass dies
wirklich keine Substanz ist, die wir mit unserem Verstand
nicht erfassen können, also wirklich, da das
Unmögliche
durch unseren produziert wird  Das Scheitern,
es zu erreichen, das ist ein sehr hegelianischer lacanianischer
Gedanke, dass
wir immer scheitern, aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass
wir etwas verpassen  Ja, wir vermissen etwas,
aber dass etwas nur durch
unsere Fehler entsteht,
hier bin ich transzendentaler, hier
würde ich den Unterschied zwischen
Schlucht zwischen Realität und das reale
Realität vorstellen, es ist, was es
wirklich ist, das
ist diese
rein virtuelle
[Musik],
aber  in diesem genauen Sinne, dass
es real ist,
weil wir es nicht wirklich
symbolisieren können, ja wir, es ist
schon der Tod ist vielleicht so etwas wie
das. Gute Philosophen haben
sogar einmal
gesagt, dass er nicht meine Art von Gesetz ist, aber er sagte, dass
es Dinge wie Todesschrecken und
so weiter gibt  Sie können all diese mythologischen Beispiele einfach nicht
wirklich in unseren alltäglichen Realitätssinn integrieren.
Zum Beispiel stellen wir uns gerne eine
glückliche traditionelle Zeit vor, in der das Sterben ein
normaler Prozess war. Die ganze Familie war
um Sie herum. Sie starben ruhig. Das ist ein
rückwirkender
Mythos  Punkt jede Realität
schließt etwas aus,
manches schließt es in dem Sinne aus, dass wir
es nicht in unseren
Bedeutungshorizont integrieren können  g
und ich denke,
das ist hier passiert, deshalb
mag ich cherie, weißt du,
okay, ein bisschen weit von hier auf der
anderen seite unter der universität gibt es
das
datenkabarett, das ist übrigens, aber es ist
ein fake, das kann nicht passiert sein  Sie
wissen, es ist meine Lieblingstheorie über den
Ursprung des Namens Dada,
es ist eine Fälschung, aber es ist schön, Sie wissen,
dass
Lenin genau zu dieser Zeit buchstäblich um die Ecke lebte, und das
Fleisch ist ein schöner Mythos, den Lenin
einmal besucht hat, bevor er
Dadaismus genannt wurde  ihre leistung und applaudierten
und sagten dada, was auf russisch ja ja bedeutet,
sie nahmen
leider es ist ein mythos ich denke, dass man
zwischen moderner kunst und
radikalen politischen bewegungen nie
konsonanten findet, das ist alles der traum
radikaler künstler
wie futuristen in der sowjetunion, die wir
sein werden  künstlerisches Gegenstück von und
so weiter nein nein nein es funktioniert nicht aber tut mir leid
ist
[Musik]
Ich möchte hier etwas hinzufügen, von dem Sie wahrscheinlich wissen,
dass es sogar heute noch
versucht wird  vermeide diese schlussfolgerung zum
beispiel
er ist jetzt glaube ich zumindest
in podcasts in deutschland sehr beliebt die
physikalisch theoretikerin sabine hosenfelder
sie versucht sie geht im grunde auf
einstein zurück und behauptet, dass diese
unbestimmtheitsüberlagerung einfach bedeutet,
dass unser wissen der realität
unvollständig
ist
ähm
und er ist für mich eines der authentischen
Genies der Wissenschaft des 20. Jahrhunderts und
im Allgemeinen, wenn ich hier wiederholen darf, was ich
bereits 50 Mal in meinem Buch
getan habe, hat Niels Bohr die beste Definition gegeben, die
ich kenne, wie Ideologie heute funktioniert,
aber es wird angenommen  wahr ist, dass
bohr ein haus auf dem land gebaut hat, wo
über dem eingang ein hufeisen war,
das angeblich böse
geister am eindringen hindert und der freund sich
selbst besucht, aber du bist wissenschaftler, du bist
nicht abergläubisch, warum hast du das
und bohr hat geantwortet  Natürlich bin ich ein
Wissenschaftler, ich glaube nicht daran, aber mir
wurde gesagt, dass es funktioniert, auch wenn Sie nicht
daran glauben
, das ist eine Ideologie, die
wir alle sind  Zynisch glauben wir nicht
daran, aber wir verlassen uns irgendwie darauf, dass es
funktioniert, aber zurück zu diesem Quantenproblem
, wissen Sie, was ich in meinen Büchern getan habe? Es sind
vielleicht zwei weiße Spekulationen
formuliert die Hypothese, dass es
unter unserer eigenen
gewöhnlichen Realität mit festem
Objekt eine andere virtuelle potenzielle Realität gibt,
die mehrdeutiger geflickt wird und so
weiter, aber jetzt komme ich wieder zum
zentralen Punkt
,
bohr
hat richtig hegelisch gedacht, was
andere vor ihm dachten  Nur die
Begrenzung unseres Wissens, sagte er, nein
mein Gott, warum konnte es nicht in der Sache
selbst liegen,
warum kann die Sache selbst nicht
unbestimmt sein, das ist für mich äußerst
wichtig, weil
es uns wieder erlaubt, uns
unter unsere gewöhnliche Vorstellung von Realität zu bewegen, statt darüber hinaus
Das ist immer noch, denke ich, aus dem
19. Jahrhundert stammend, war die
Grundidee, was die ultimative Realität ist, ein leerer
Raum, in dem einige kleine Partikel
auf und ab springen  nein,
aber wenn ich jetzt ein anderes beispiel
aus meinen büchern nehmen darf, das ist es, was
mich wirklich fasziniert, nämlich dass ich
mir die
geologischen folgen dieser
unvollständigkeit der realität vorstelle und ich fand in
einer einführung in die philosophie von nicolas
fern er ist aggressiv analytisch er hasst
meine theorie wahrscheinlich aber er  hat eine
wundervolle Beobachtung gemacht,
er sagt, dass wir
uns diese Unvollkommenheit
der Realität vorstellen oder als Effekt von Gottes
Faulheit interpretieren können. Schau
ja, warum er diesen Typen benutzt, eine wunderbare
Parallele, sagte er, schau, du spielst ein Videospiel
und natürlich, wenn es nicht so ist, gehst du
auf der straße, die im
hintergrund schießt, sieht man
wald natürlich hat der programmierer dort nicht
alle bäume im detail programmiert, weil
es nicht teil des spiels ist, dass man
dorthin geht, er hat es unvollständig gelassen und er hat gesagt,
was es mit gott ist  Er
sagte, die Menschen sind zu dumm, sie
werden niemals die subatomare Ebene erreichen, also ist
mir
die Vorstellung egal, dass wir es waren,
und dies wäre für mich das richtige, aber
wir  kann später darüber sprechen nicht Kirk
Wächter Position
ja
nein Waffentruppen nein nein ich
es wäre schwer weil ich
zu Pascal zurückkehren müsste du weißt Pascals
vette wagner
er meint das nicht
einfach eine
detaillierte analyse hat gezeigt das es seine
idee nicht ist wenn du anziehst  Glaube nicht, tue so, als ob
du glaubst und der Glaube kommt oder
was auch immer,
nein, im Grunde genommen,
wenn du Pascal Hispancy wirklich im Detail liest, ist
seine Idee, dass, wenn du weißt, dass Gott
glaubt, aber nicht so tust, als ob, sondern so tust und tust
, als ob er dir glaubt  ein üblicher
religiöser mensch uninteressant bist wenn du
als gott handelst wenn du nicht an gott glaubst und so tust
als ob gott nicht existiert bist du
ein säkularer philosoph die dinge werden
interessant wenn du
paradoxerweise beides verbindest wie die
übliche
humanistische agnostische position  Ich weiß, dass Gott
nicht existiert, aber aus Respekt vor der
Tradition tue ich so, als ob er existiert, es hilft,
aber die Position des wahren Kierkegaard ist
viel verrückter, ich weiß, dass Gott
existiert, aber ich werde so tun, als ob er nicht
existiert,
und ich  Denken Sie, wenn Sie Gott ersetzen  Mit dem
heutigen Gott, der wissenschaftlicher
Determinismus ist,
okay
, das sollte unsere Position sein.
Ja, ich weiß, die
Wissenschaft sagt uns, dass wir nicht
frei sind, aber ich werde verrückte Dinge tun
auf eine sehr kritische weise
ohne
schlussfolgerungen über den kapitalismus zu akzeptieren ich bleibe
hier ein marxist jetzt erste gute dinge
über den kapitalismus du weißt heute es ist so
modisch zu sagen oh schau dir die dritte
welt an wir haben ihre überreste alter
traditionen
sie sollten
sie als verwenden  Widerstand gegen den
globalen Kapitalismus Nein, ich denke, mit all
den Schrecken, die die
Globalisierung hervorgebracht hat,
schafft sie einen Raum für neue Gründe, und das
war immer das Dogma von Marx.
Ja, wir
müssen durch den Kapitalismus zu einer anderen
Ordnung gehen, aber
wir können dies nur durch den Kapitalismus tun,
weil der Kapitalismus alles zerstört
Traditionelle Werte, Allgemeinheiten und so
weiter.
Ja, Marx war hier immer sehr klar, also
bin ich absolut nicht in dieser Position
ricanische lateinamerikanische Länder sind
der einzige Raum Frankreichs,
aber das Problem mit Marx ist,
wie er sich vorstellte, wie das Iberindum
durch den Kapitalismus ging.
Ich würde sagen, dass Marx
des Kommunismus der Kapitalismus war
wo wir die marxistische tina und
hinata sehen ist
china für mich
das tiefste paradoxon und die größte
gefahr heute sie wissen was ich ihnen geben
werde eine sehr einfache definition
bestimmt
wir die alten linken des 20. jahrhunderts
hassten am kapitalismus zwei dinge
einerseits brutaler marktwettbewerb wo
Sommerreichweite Millionen
sind sehr arm
und eine starke staatliche Kontrolle
hat China die beiden nicht auf
die effizienteste
Weise vereint,
also denke ich, dass
China,
obwohl ich ihre Vorgehensweise bewundere,
nicht dumm ist,
sie sehen die Probleme mit dem liberalen
Kapitalismus, aber auf lange Sicht  Begriff Ich sehe keine
Lösung darin
Ich bin Ich bin hier
Ich habe Angst vor ähm,
wenn überhaupt, ist
meine Utopie eine Verhandlung und fr
Amdunk mit anderen Worten, das ist sehr persönlich. Sie
wissen jetzt, dass wir wissen, dass
traditionelle Sozialdemokratie und realer
Sozialismus nicht mehr funktionieren müssen.
Einige verzweifelte Linke klammern sich an diese
lokale nicht repräsentative Demokratie.
Stellen Sie sich vor, Sie leben in einer kleinen authentischen
Gemeinschaft, in der Sie sich regelmäßig mit anderen
treffen  def du
bestimmst wie wir unsere kinder punkten
was wir mit der umwelt machen und so weiter
ich kann mir keine schrecklichere welt vorstellen
jeden nachmittag muss ich darüber
reden wo bekommen wir wasser strom
nein ich will
ich will einen anonymen nicht zu bedrückenden
mechanismus
Um sich um all diese Dinge zu kümmern
, muss es für mich da draußen undurchsichtig
sein. Ich
denke, dies ist der einzige Raum der
Freiheit,
und daher ist meine Utopie, dass
ich in Spanien einen Vortrag gehalten habe. Sie waren schockiert
, dass sie mich angegriffen haben,
weil sie mir dieselbe Frage gestellt haben  wie
Sie
meine Antwort war, rationaler bürokratischer
Kapitalismus ist Sozialismus, Sie wissen, dass Sie
den Markt zulassen, aber es ist heute klar,
dass dies mein großes Argument ist, sogar für den Kriegskommunismus
Bei all den Schwierigkeiten, in denen wir uns jetzt befinden, Krieg,
Pandemie,
Möglichkeiten von Hunger, Einwanderungen, ich
spreche nicht von der Abschaffung der Märkte, eine
Weltregierung hätte heute eine
unglaubliche Korruption bedeutet,
darüber sollten wir besser nicht nachdenken, aber wir müssen
einen Weg finden, um eine
internationale Zusammenarbeit und eine minimale
direkte Kontrolle zu minimieren  die märkte schauen auf die
globale erwärmung was passierte
erinnerst du dich letzten sommer an
meinen lieblingsplätzen fast überall auf der welt
vancouver seattle portland temperaturen
von 50 grad
ja aber du weißt worauf es ankommt das
hat nichts mit der lokalen verschmutzung zu tun
die ganze luftzirkulation
am nordpol  unterbrochen wird, d.
h.
nur durch strenge internationale starke
Zusammenarbeit, und das Problem ist, wie man es
erfindet, denn wann immer wir in
Schwierigkeiten sind, ziehen wir uns
auf Protektionismus zurück, werden wir in der Lage
sein
, sie zu lösen, ich denke, es ist eine Frage des
Überlebens für uns, nur in diesem Sinne
vergessen  über das Zentralkomitee gibt es
einen Tag oder was auch immer im 20. Jahrhundert werden
wir in der Lage sein
lösen, um eine lösung für uns zu finden,
aber du weißt, wie ich
mich selbst definiere, das ist meine neue definition,
die alle meine
linken freunde entsetzt
du weißt, was ich
an intelligenten gemäßigten
konservativen
schätze lenin gefiel das an ihnen er schrieb das
er sagte
sie meinen es ernst sie sind keine
billigen liberalen die nur dinge versprechen
wohlfahrt
ein guter
konservativer denkt immer an
warte mal was sind die gefahren was wird  sei
der preis, den wir dafür zahlen müssen also
ich spreche nicht von trumpian populist
was auch immer
konservativ
nein weil ich immer noch radikal bin ich denke
radikale änderungen werden notwendig sein ich
denke wir werden
wir nähern uns zumindest der hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit einer globalen krise  Erwärmung
bedeutet,
dass jetzt in Indien und so weiter bedeutet
weniger Nahrung bedeutet neue Migrationen, was passieren wird
, wenn zum Beispiel aus dem Nahen Osten,
wo
ich wirklich war  dort habe ich es überprüft ich
war als tourist in dubai als die
temperatur auf 55 anstieg
und sogar die einheimischen sagten mir nein nein
es ist nicht so, dass wir uns daran gewöhnen können es ist
unglaublich so große änderungen
müssen stattfinden wie es ohne geht  Krieg
, das ist
das Problem,
aber wir haben auch Armut, deshalb ein
weiterer Schock für meine linken Freunde. Ich
glaube nicht, dass ich diesen Fokus auf Einwanderung nicht mag.
Sie wissen, wir sollten
unsere Türen öffnen. Nein, wenn wir unsere Türen
öffnen, öffnen wir einfach  wird Millionen hier haben und dann werden
normale Leute
Populisten dagegen stimmen wir
werden einen Bürgerkrieg haben oder was auch immer ich denke,
dass das Problem nicht darin besteht,
die Tür nach hier zu öffnen, sondern um
es sehr einfach auszudrücken, jetzt die
Situation anzusprechen, warum sie hierher kommen  Wir
müssen das ganze System ändern, weil
Sie wissen, was auch mein Problem mit
Einwanderern ist. Vergessen Sie nie etwas.
Meistens kommen nicht die wirklich Armen
hierher.
Diejenigen, die hierher kommen, sind normalerweise viele von
ihnen. Sie müssen Geld haben, um sie
zu bezahlen  Die Schmuggler und so weiter und
so weiter haben einen anderen
Ansatz entwickelt
ja und ich weißt du weißt
ja ja du weißt jetzt ich sie gaben mir eine
wunderbare Antwort jetzt veröffentliche ich viel
mit einem in Deutschland entwickelten Paradox,
das moderat konservativ ist und du weißt,
ich habe  ein dialog mit ihnen ich habe ihnen gesagt
aber trotzdem bin ich irgendwie
kommunist obwohl moderat
konservativ warum veröffentlichst du mich und
du weißt was ich von denen geantwortet habe
kein problem weil wir moderat
kommunistisch konservativ sind
wie man in casablanca sagt anfang a
schöne freundschaft
ist ja,
weil ich hasse
ich hasse
spiegel
ich hasse uh mich selbst auf der leinwand zu sehen
ich habe keinen der filme gesehen in denen
ich
mich fühle wie
nein aber nein nein es ist nicht
postmoderne arroganz oder was auch immer ich bin
ich spiele kein spiel mit all meinen
nervenstöcken und so weiter wenn ich mich
länger als eine minute auf dem bildschirm sehe
ich kann es nicht ich kann es nicht
das ist
nein das problem ist das ich es
bin aber mir gefällt nicht was ich sehe  das ist ein
Ekelhafter, nervöser Typ,
ich bin im Grunde ein Schriftsteller, obwohl ich auch
gerne bla bla rede,
deshalb
werde ich etwas anderes
tun  Du machst das nicht mit zu wenig
Details, aber du hörst meine Stimme und dann
stellst du meine Stimme in den Hintergrund und
jemand liest die Übersetzung, wo du
sie manipulieren und falsch übersetzen kannst.
Ich bin von Natur aus böse,
ja,
schneller und
du weißt, frag mich, was das ist  Bedeutung von
Tod und Leben und dann werde ich sagen, dass einige
zen-buddhistische Scheiße wie Klatschen mit
Sitzen perfekt sind. Ja, ihr wisst alle,
sogar ich definiere mich
paradoxerweise als atheistischer Christ,
aber ich mag, was ich gesagt habe,
er, was er sagt, ist
Wahnsinn, er ist nicht weise  er bringt
radikale
umwälzungen
für mich die verkörperung der weisheit
sind sprichwörter und ich weiß nicht wie es
mit deiner sprache ist aber in meiner sprache
kann ich mir nichts
ekelhafteres vorstellen als sprichwörter
was immer du auch machst  Lassen Sie sich durch ein
Sprichwort rechtfertigen Sagen wir, Sie tun etwas Riskantes
und haben Erfolg. Dann werde ich als
Weiser kommen und sagen: Ja, ja,
wir haben ein Sprichwort.
Nur diejenigen, die den
Gewinn riskieren, wissen, dass ich gerechtfertigt bin
ich werde wiederkommen und etwas sagen wir
haben auf slowenisch ein sehr vulgäres sprichwort
uriniere nicht gegen den wind denn
dann wirst
du wissen das ist für mich die wahrheit der
weisheit dass sie rückwirkend
alles rechtfertigen kann also für mich tun wir es nicht  Ich brauche keine
Weisheit, die einen falschen
Frieden gibt, was wäre die Weisheit. Ich habe
es einmal
auf parodistische Weise versucht, aber ich habe es in Israel getan,
und es gab sogar Leute mit
tätowierten Schildern, die mir
zustimmten.  Das Ekelhafteste ist
, sagen wir mal, ein Weiser, vielleicht ein Nazi, kommt
zu
Juden, wo sie verhungern, und
sagt ihnen so etwas wie: Gib dich
mit seinem Leiden ab, ist Teil des Lichts, du kannst
immer ein kleines Stück
Glück finden, selbst hier das  ist eine Obszönität,
das ist Weisheit für mich, wir brauchen Wahnsinn, wir
brauchen gut durchdachte, aber trotzdem
Verkörperung des Volkes, wenn wir die
Macht übernehmen,
wirst du nicht in den Gulak gehen, nur es
wären gute zwei, drei Jahre Trunks
[Musik] für
dich